claudia dantschke also expands speech on
this topic
because the girls are around 15 16 17
and the apprenticeship appealed to you
there are networks on facebook and so
on and there are women who
then network these girls,
recruit them in part and
ultimately prepare systematic departure
That means everything is highly
professional.
The problem is that often these underage girls
don’t travel alone,
but there is usually an older one with them,
that means two girls who are 5 14 15
16 and everyone who is over 18 is
the old person, so to speak, part of the
authorities there  like a kind of
supervisor that means
having the hope that the turkish
border would be taken like a stimulus would be
vigilant to notice this
this hope we have to look at the
internet if you can thanks to the internet you ca
n’t use facebook etc
if you find something the police just the
police  and the direction of the
public prosecutor's office, yes, they still have
to do this  give people a bit
harder penalties things hate speech
young people need media skills they
don't need censorship young people
don't start radicalizing themselves on the internet
as it is not so that they
look on the internet and then suddenly become
radical first of all they have
some problems themselves
what can i do  school should only do that can be
with the parents since if you can't find a
solution to your problems
suddenly someone started on the internet
or school
rathen friend suddenly like that first
step
that means suddenly there is someone who
understands this young change version woman
that appeals to the girls  change because that's
actually how it is, because
they brought all their rights, some of them
grew up, so the girls go there, the girls
don't see that
their rights are then robbed, a girl, for
example, otherwise only very conservative,
traditional Muslim
quotes, family comes from where
brother al  Les was allowed and the girl
not then the girl says the girl
can emancipate herself from this family through this radical ideology
other girls openly liberal
society say it like that from families of origin
German
the parents divorced two times
remarried patchwork families
the girl feels she has to  to be
recognized in this society she has
to do everything
she has to get married she has to have children
she has to be successful
in her job can be exhausting she is respected there in the
traditional role of a woman she is a
housewife mother supports her husband
in his mission and is
respected for it, and very much so  can also be
attractive or very classic
girl quite different from young that
means the thing i am writing
world history the caliphate as
revealed by the prophet prophesied in
syria the new caliphate is here i
belong to the first generation
i will give children i will help build a new state
on
whether  backdrop